je suis favorable à la pénalisation du
client
l'achat d'un acte sexuel correspond à la
mise à disposition du corps des femmes
pour les hommes indépendamment du désir
de celles ci c'était le mois dernier
roselyne bachelot était auditionnée par
la mission d'information parlementaire
présidée par la députée socialiste
danielle bousquet une mission
d'information sur la prostitution en
france
à l'arrivée 30 propositions rendu public
le 13 avril la plus importante la
pénalisation des clients
à l'instar de la suède c'est
parlementaires français voudraient après
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 faire
voter une loi criminalisant l'achat de
services sexuels qui serait sanctionné
par six mois de prison et 3000 euros
damende une bonne idée pour certaines
associations féministes l' approche
répressive est le seul moyen pour thalia
breton de faire comprendre que le corps
humain ne peut se vendre ou se louer on
considère que la prostitution et avoir
des relations sexuelles sans plaisir et
sans désir c'est une violence qui est
faite aux femmes donc c'est pas
tolérable pour des questions de refus de
marchandisation du corps comme on refuse
la vente d'organes par exemple où la
gestation pour autrui on refuse qu'il
soit possible dans une société d'acheter
ou louer le corps des femmes
à partir du moment où dans une société
on considère où on dit au petit garçon
que c'est possible d'aller louer le
corps d'une femme ou d'avoir des
relations sexuelles tarifées sans
s'occuper du plaisir ou du désir d'une
femme ça une conséquence sur l'ensemble
des femmes et on ne pourra pas
construire une société égalitaire s'il
ya encore de la prostitution d'une
sanction moralisatrice qui scandalise
sarah marie maffesoli l'état n'a pas à
dicter la conduite des gens et pénaliser
les clients ne fera que déplacer le
problème en fragilisant une fois de plus
le statut déjà précaire des prostituées
ça ne fera qu'aggraver le problème de la
traite et de l'exploitation des êtres
humains et cela ne fera qu'aggraver le
problème de l'accès aux droits des
travailleurs sexuels
on est contre le travail sexuel mais
comme on ne veut pas dire qu on est
dérangé par le fait de voir les
travailleurs du sexe bah on dit qu'on va
s'attaquer aux clients parce que ce sont
eux les mauvais la réalité c'est que ce
qui dérange c'est le travail sexuel et
autant les travailleurs sexuels que les
clients des travailleurs sexuels
en france il y aurait 20 mille
prostituées 80 % seraient des femmes
mais difficile de savoir exactement car
depuis la loi de 2003 sur le racolage
passif
les prostituées ont quitté les centre
villes repoussés en périphérie dans des
parcs ou des forêts elles sont davantage
exposées aux agressions criminaliser les
clients ce serait donc une nouvelle fois
stigmatisé les prostituées il ne faut
pas confondre la loi et la morale pour
cet anthropologue la prohibition risque
même d'entraîner plus de violence et ne
règlerait surtout aucun problème
la criminalisation n'a jamais rien
empêché si elle le fait d'être autrefois
puni de la peine de mort ou aujourd'hui
de la prison à perpétuité empêcher les
crises à sorel et quand il ya une crise
économique grave on se sent en
insécurité on a besoin de boucs
émissaires et qu'elle sonne au bouc
émissaire aujourd'hui ce sont les
musulmans les migrants
les sans-papiers et
les jeunes et puis les prostituées
moralisatrice liberticide pour certains
protectrice ou progressistes pour
d'autres cette loi au poste de vision
quoi qu'il en soit en suède où la
prostitution est interdite depuis dix
ans le recours aux travailleurs sexuels
auraient baissé de 50% fait des bouchons
jérôme nos idéaux bonsoir nous venons de
voir un reportage de christophe
kulikauskis à propos de la polémique
suscitée par le rapport de la mission
d'information sur la prostitution en
france
il propose une future loi qui créerait
un nouveau délit un des lignes une
infraction pénale sanctionnant le
recours à la prostitution avec une peine
de six mois de prison et de trois mille
euros damende la polémique qui nous a
conduits à nous poser la question en
matière de prostitution
doit-on pénaliser les clients âgés
souhaité en parler avec vous vous
philippe goujon vous êtes maire du xvème
arrondissement de paris député ump de la
12e circonscription membres de la
commission d'information da prostitution
en france donc concernés créé en 2010
par la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale je vous pose la
question en matière de prostitution
doit-on pénaliser les clients ben pour
moi la réponse est claire c'est oui
en tant qu'élus nous sommes partis du
respect des valeurs fondamentales de la
république
tout simplement à savoir l'égalité entre
l'homme et la femme
la dignité humaine la non patrimonialité
du corps humain et donc ça non
marchandisation et la lutte contre les
violences et notamment l évidence et aux
femmes
d'accord le vous jérôme et nos élus vous
êtes capotier or yeux expliqué un peu ce
qu'il en est de ce métier qui est devenu
une marque
d'ailleurs ce qui vous concerne vous
êtes entrepreneurs et fournisseurs de
préservatifs aux prostituées de younes
fait quand même sept cent mille par an
dans un rayon de 100 kilomètres ailleurs
vous demandez également dans toute la
france vous connaissez bien ces femmes
et donc vous avez vous aussi un avis sur
la question en matière de prostitution
doit-on pénaliser les clients non il
faut absolument pas pénaliser les
clients pour des raisons une raison
toute simple c'est qu'on va aller vers
de la précarité vers de la violence
auprès des députés fait par les faits
par les clients ils savent les relations
vont se passer dans des temps des dieux
beaucoup plus excentrée à l'abri bien
sûr des regards mais le la violence va
apparaître de manière évidente si jamais
on pénalise les clients pourraient se
cacher pour aller voir les prostituées
je crois que la localité et la précarité
et la violence existe déjà et ô combien
vous savez bien que aujourd'hui les
prostituées risque 100 fois plus d'être
assassiné que les autres femmes dans ce
pays
quel risque 50 fois plus près d'être
violentée que la quasi-totalité des
prostituées a commencé malheureusement
par des viols
donc ce que nous souhaitons nous c'est
vraiment faire respecter le corps humain
du consciente le corps humain n'est pas
à louer et d'ailleurs les pays dans
lesquels la peña d'asie
nous aurons à les verts
le maximum de mesures pour empêcher la
prostitution mais aujourd'hui il y a le
délit de racolage il ya le délai
proxénétisme est le seul partenaire si
je peux dire qui n'est pas mise en cause
c'est le client c'est tout à fait
injuste
la prostituée moi je la considère
largement comme une victime alors que le
client est celui qui permet la
processionnaire dans les pourparlers
il faut parler de l'époque dans lequel
on est et pour voir la constitution
comme il se pratique actuellement il
faut quand même contrairement à ce que
vous dites dans le rapport qui est sorti
la semaine dernière
non mais la gauche je suis bien entendu
assez consensuel il faut il faut il faut
bien point que dans ce rapport on j'ai
vu le nombre de personnes que vous avez
rencontrées vous avez consulté
vous n'allez pas rencontrer un client et
vous ai pas rencontré de prostituées en
activité vous avez rencontré que des
prostituées qui sont qui ont arrêté qui
sont à la retraite si j'ose dire et
maintenant les prostituées que je
fréquente que je vois tous les jour de
manière quotidienne
une grande majorité c'est là on va pas
être d'accord sont libres et moi je suis
bien d'accord
non mais attendez laissez moi finir
parce que ce qu'il faut bien savoir
c'est qui on est bien qu'on a bien
conscience avec les prostituées
parce que nous les voyons les premiers
qu'il ya des raisons qui vient des
prothèses encore le disent pas
essentielle est celle là où il faut agir
vert agir auprès du client en disant
monsieur favre aller voir les
prostituées sinon on va vous pénaliser
il faut agir au niveau des réseaux et
des procès là il vient des blues en
existe pour ça l'armement et les sons et
filles lire travailler c'est le
gouvernement actuel qui a doublé les
effectifs de look très qui est le
service spécialisé de lutte contre le
proxénétisme lavande quarantaine de
réseaux mafieux qui sont des ventes et
chaque année d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce qui existait avant
les années 90 il
la quasi-totalité des prostituées sont
étrangère dans ce pays ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'elles sont prises en
main par des réseaux mafieux qui les
captures pas ce qu'ils font on ne peut
pas parler autrement dans les pays en
question soit validé en soi d'europe de
l'est qui ensuite les exploitent les les
met en condition dans des maisons de
dressage où elles sont violées battues
affamés où elle considère presque la
prostitution doit publiques en france
comme une libération
mais ce n'est pas une libération c'est
au contraire un esclavagisme et c'est ça
que nous voulons empêcher mais plus
possible mais nous devrons on est en
force et aussi la lutte contre
l'occident et les consciences en sorte
que je voudrais surtout je vais vous
dire moi donc je ferai quand je vais
livrer aux prostituées respectivement je
suis fabricants de préservatifs une
camionnette on me téléphone on me laisse
des messages et je vais livrer les
prostituées sur leur lieu de travail
d'accord et nous donc de revenir sur le
problème des réseaux on les voit le mois
quand vient livrer et les professionnels
libres on voit bien quand il ya des
nouvelles filles qui arrivent et qui
sont tristes qui ont un regard lugubre
et qui sont l'aide à 3,4 groupe et sur
un angle de trottoir on les voit bien et
moi je connais très bien très bien
la police judiciaire de lyon aussi bien
les moeurs de la répression du
proxénétisme
ils me le disent on les voit les réseaux
le problème c'est qu'ils manquent de
moyens pas beaucoup pas beaucoup de
moyens il faut pas doubler les effectifs
mais il manque un tout petit peu de
moyens pour arrêter ce fléau que sont
les réseaux et des praticiens d'être
passionnant quand tu peux me suit plus
les professionnels des années 70 ça n'a
rien avoir séduit un proxénète qui
frappe qui viole tu ça ça n'existe plus
je peux vous dire ça n'existe pas dans
son garage qui résume tout net tu
reprends un petit peu de tout perdre
je veux bien qu'on éradique tout ça mais
il faut bien penser que contrairement à
l'impression que vous avez si vous venez
avec moi sur terrain mais vous ne verrez
que les majorités au dessert une fille
sont libres et j'ai 15 ans et je termine
nous avons déjà eu une expérience à
paris à laquelle j'ai participé
d'ailleurs qui était la fermeture du
bois de boulogne dans les années 90 par
un accord entre jacques chirac et le
maire de paris est vite fait son premier
ministre parce qu'il y avait cette
épidémie de sida ont été très importants
cette opération a consisté largement à
mettre en cause le client par des
contrôles d'identité par des enlèvements
de véhicules par des impossibilités
d'aller dans l'est dans le bois de
boulogne par des interdictions de
passage ça a donné de très bons
résultats c'est à dire il aujourd'hui
alors que nous avions 1000 à 1500
prostituées traversy dans votre blog
aujourd'hui nous en avons
ils ont une centaine vous prenez le
problème par la fin annoncée n'a
finalement le client si si c'est la
mesure est souvent quand vous le
souhaitez mais la demande plutôt de
supprimer l'offre pour supprimer réagir
sur leurs notes sur neymar clients et 6
ou parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison que
nos clients soient les réseaux le sun
pénalisé parce que les clients prennent
le relais libre
non non non non non non non les
personnes qui l' enfant de la balle est
libre et les conques n'est pas un match
c'est sa brève
non personne majeure vous avez un rat
brun rouge et non tu arrivé c'est un
rapport livré concentre à partir de ses
tarifs et ce n'est pas qu'on s'entend il
s'agit de là pourquoi pas raison de la
pression et les verrines à quel point ça
de son plein gré ce qui est proposé par
exemple ces endroits il faut de l'accès
à des papiers il faut de l'accès au
logement soit au travail mais c'est très
difficile parce que quand vous avez un
revenu très important par la
prostitution même si une bonne partie
l'avez pas vous du temps et s'ils n'ont
pas de papiers comment nous faisons en
sorte aujourd'hui fric ya des lois qui
permettent à partir régulariser ma 6e à
partir du moment où on dénonce de
proxénètes on est régularisée évidemment
c'est difficile parce qu'il faut
accepter de sortir du système c'est très
difficile je n'en disconviens pas mais
nous avons des mesures aujourd'hui qui
permettent à ces personnes d'obtenir des
papiers bien sûr parce que l'émotion
comme des victimes seront tous deux une
petite sur les réseaux mafieux et
criminel
d'ailleurs on s'en va et la toxicomanie
ou à se prostituer savoir que maintenant
les jeunes africaines c'est pas
tellement des professionnels qui les
hommes c'est des passeurs qui les ont
fait venir
oui mais je vais vous en dit long mois
le résultat est le même mais qu'est ce
qu'elle vous voulez qu'elle fasse l ont
pas pire reporte boulot une fois que les
arrivées en france malheureusement elle
se trouve dans l'après créateurs seront
présentes on parlait d'une copine qui
s'est prostituée c'est le seul moyen
qu'ils ont pour régler leurs dettes et
n'ouvre année dans celle de
l'alimentation leurs plans patron qui la
mesure d'eau qu'elle ne viserait
surpasser s'il s'agit revenir oui
qu'est-ce que ça arrive c'est
intéressant de sa déjà vous qu'est ce
que ça aurait au moins deux puissances
ayant conscience le client prendre
conscience des cartes chose qui est
attentatoire à la dignité humaine parce
que là il n'a pas conscience du tout ça
fait partie de la rigolade
oui tiens enfin je parle pas de certains
footballeurs n'est ce pas qui ont
défrayé la chronique mais c'est un peu
ça pour son anniversaire mais aussi ceux
là c'est tout ça va les rendre
acceptables donc c'est de faire prendre
conscience que quelque chose de normal
et qu'on doit pas tenter la dignité du
maine premièrement deuxièmement c'est
une mesure qui doit être évidemment
compléter et le rapport fait trente
propositions quand même qui doit être
complété par des mesures d'ordre social
bien sûr et des mesures aussi qui
permettent de biomécanique en croit le
proxénète fréhel à la fermeture des
maisons closes on avait prévu ccco
mesures sociales d'après affaire marc
trijaud et ça n'a jamais été mieux oui
sauf que la prostitution a
considérablement diminué par rapport à
cette époque donc la chose évolué je
pense que personne enfin aujourd'hui ne
prétend rouvrir les maisons closes pour
la méditation à l'allemande née à 400000
prostituées contre une vingtaine de
milliers en france même si les chiffres
sont difficiles
les héros sans coeur comme en allemagne
c'est pas des souhaits ce sont des
solutions à savoir des lentilles
solution je bronze hélas que c'est-il
exploitation reconnu par l'état par
l'état
du corps de la femme c'est encore pire
que tout non non ça évidemment il n'en
est pas question
mais que dites vous à quelqu'un qui est
sur le terrain qui vous dit la
proposition ne fait que me grey quand
vous lui interdisez danse hors des
villes
a lyon on a vu avec le maire qui est
donc socialistes dont québec gérard
collomb il a voulu supprimer la
protection du centre ville qu'est ce que
ça fait ça créé il ya toujours autant de
prostituées je dirais qu'il ya peut-être
moins deux prostituées mais il ya
toujours autant de clients est-ce que ce
déficit est ce que vous concéder une
certaine expérience de terrain à votre
interlocuteur quand il vous donne donne
les éléments et les arguments qui vous
donne est ce que ça vous interroge vous
interpelle vous vous considérez que
c'est simplement un exemple marginal non
mais tous les exemples sont moins
d'abord nous avons auditionné des
dizaines et des dizaines de responsables
de toutes sortes on aurait peut-être dû
vous additionnez d'ailleurs les
intéressants pourra le faire d'ailleurs
à l'occasion mais nous avons eu des gens
qui développait les arguments qui sont
les vôtres
nous avons considéré vraiment en
conscience qu'il n'était pas recevable
et qui ne devait pas nous empêcher
d'essayer de lutter contre ce fléau qui
d'ailleurs est extraordinairement
sexistes puisque on veut dire que nos
offres situées sur 10 grammes des femmes
alors vous avez vous envie juste à ce
propos en matière de conclusion vous
avait balayé la réouverture des maisons
closes qu'est ce que vous proposez vous
est proposé
la pénalisation et cette pénalisation
qu'est-ce que assorti de mesures
d'accompagnement social et de lutte
renforcée contre le proxénétisme vous
aurez les moyens de cet accompagnement
social
c'est un tout notre rapport ce n'est pas
une mesure ces 30 mesures
il ya des moyens financiers
effectivement de réinsertion sociale
mais aussi beaucoup de mesures d'accès
au droit de prise en considération de
ces personnes et ces d'organisation de
réseaux n'ont pas de programme et de
sorties la prostitution
j'ai envie aux idéaux vous votre
sentiment et propositions pour conclure
ont conclu aux tirs dont j'ai déjà parlé
m claude les filles n'en veulent pas moi
j'en ai parlé beaucoup avec les
prostituées elles veulent pas la
relation brosse à cela parce que le
rouble les maisons closes c'est à
nouveau le procédé du bateau relatives à
arriver le blanchiment d'argent sur
celles n'en veulent pas non c'est la
voie publique car il faut ce qu'il faut
organiser ces des lieux de prostitution
éventuellement à l'abri des regards
comme ça se passe à lyon maintenant
elles sont investies des zones des zones
industrielles qui sont complètement vide
la nuit où la personne qui vient voir
les prostituées vient pour sa terre pas
un bureau de tabac y apprend un varia
rien la personne qui vient s'étendre là
qui vient voir les filles c'est clair
c'est net et précis
et concernant les produits par elle-même
il faut absolument que vous écoutiez que
vous veniez voir et que vous rencontriez
les lettres urgent les prostituées
libres parce qu'il y en a et au moins
que vous puissiez leur dire à celles ci
vous êtes libre à d'accord pour
renouveler la convention d'entraidé les
hijras conclure qu'elle est simplement
la suite de ce rapport qu'elle et
l'échéancier alors les gens cessent et
que nous avons rencontré le miz la
solidarité le business
la justice qui vont étudier ces
propositions et d'ici quelques mois de
juin la loi va être
et d'ici quelques mois j'espère
l'assemblée nous soit nous ferons une
proposition de loi soit ce sera un
projet gouvernemental donc moi je veux
rassembler messieurs on va on va suivre
la suite de ce rapport qui bougeait
jérôme veloso jour merci bonsoir bonsoir
[Musique]